comment mieux contrôler les sites
internet consultés par les mineurs
aujourd'hui une grande majorité de
fournisseurs d'accès se sont engagés à
proposer gratuitement un logiciel de
contrôle aux parents hakim abdel khaleq
guys and dolls violence pornographie
pédophilie racisme la liberté sur
internet n'a pas de limites
pas évident ce cas de laisser surfer
librement les plus jeunes mais tous les
fournisseurs d'accès sur internet
offrent maintenant des logiciels de
contrôle parental
ils sont gratuits et permettent de
filtrer à l'aide de mots clés
les informations reçues ou donner
l'exemple lorsque juliette veut écrire
son prénom sur un forum de discussion
le logiciel bloque la conversation les
parents peuvent décider de la liste des
personnes à dresser des emails à cet
enfant ils peuvent choisir des sites qui
sont particulièrement adaptés leurs
enfants l'équitation
les dessins animés ou des choses comme
celle ci et pour d'autres reprendre la
famille choisir d'autres paramètres
une liste noire de sites interdits sera
également donnée par les fournisseurs
d'accès reste que l'efficacité de ces
logiciels n'est pas assurée à 100% et
que le rôle éducatif des parents restent
essentielles faudrait pas qu'ils aient
un effet pervers c'est à dire que il ya
un effet substitutif c'est à dire que
les familles au lieu de s'approprier
cette question là et d'en débattre d'en
discuter avec leurs enfants avec les
adolescents mais qui se repose sur un
dispositif technique donc là ça serait
plutôt qu un effet négatif
actuellement moins d'un tiers des
familles sont équipés de ces logiciels
de contrôle parental
reste donc à les faire connaître une
campagne du ministère de la famille sera
lancée en maître
moment quelqu'un envoyer un message mais
je sais pas qui c'est répond non non
surtout pas clouer internet c'est comme
dans la rue tu ne parles pas aux
inconnus sur internet la sécurité ça
commence aussi par vous en faut